here's a fun geometry problem  from vertex a construct a b a c and a d  such that a b equals ac equals a d and  angle b a c is equal to 50 degrees  the question is what is the measure of  angle bdc  to solve this problem here's the trick  construct a circle centered at a whose  radius is equal to the length of a b  because a b equals ac equals ad the  circle will pass through the points b c  and d  then the arc bc has the same measure as  the central angle bac so its measure  will be equal to 50 degrees  then angle bdc is an inscribed angle of  this circle and its measure will be half  that of the arc bc  so it will be equal to 25 degrees  thus angle bdc is equal to 25 degrees  and that's the answer